plus fort que soi,
alors je suis au bon endroit,
car, l'an dernier,
j'ai passé une année passionnante grâce à « Crazy Rich Asians » que j'ai réalisé.
(Applaudissements)
Merci, merci.
Et si nous parlons de relations aujourd'hui,
c'est que mon histoire a été rendue possible
grâce à un ensemble de relations tissées au cours de ma vie.
J'espère qu'en racontant un peu de mon histoire,
j'aiderai quelqu'un à trouver sa voie un peu plus vite que moi.
L'histoire commence quand j'ai ouvert le livre sacré pour la première fois...
Le livre sacré des gadgets « The Sharper Image », bien sûr.
(Rires)
Oui, certains connaissent.
C'était un magazine de rêves
qui contenait des choses inimaginables à nos yeux,
mais elles étaient bien là.
Vous pouviez vous les faire livrer.
Des choses qui n'auraient probablement jamais dû exister,
comme un « Gregory », un mannequin grandeur nature
qui dissuade le crime par son allure puissante et masculine.
Ce n'est pas une blague.
(Rires)
Ça existe pour de vrai.
Mes yeux sont tombés sur le Video Ed/it Sima 2.
C'était un objet tellement cool quand j'avais 10 ans.
On pouvait brancher ses lecteurs VHS les uns aux autres
et faire des montages,
j'ai donc finalement convaincu mes parents de me l'acheter.
Mais avant cela,
laissez-moi vous faire un petit topo sur mes parents.
Ils sont arrivés très jeunes aux États-Unis,
de Taiwan et de Chine,
et ils se sont installés à Los Altos, en Californie –
la Silicon Valley avant la Silicon Valley.
Ils ont monté un restaurant appelé Chef Chu's.
Cinquante ans plus tard, ils y travaillent encore,
ils y sont toujours.
J'y ai grandi, c'était super.
Et en parlant de relations, c'était une plateforme de relations.
On venait y célébrer tout : anniversaires, accords commerciaux,
on mangeait, on buvait et
on créait des relations.
J'ai grandi dans cet univers.
Mes parents ont toujours vu l'Amérique comme le paradis sur Terre.
On peut,
si on aime quelque chose, travailler et accomplir ce qu'on veut.
Ils ont donc élevé leurs cinq enfants à l'américaine.
Je suis le plus jeune,
celui qui ferme les yeux sur la photo.
Ils nous ont appelés ma sœur et moi Jennifer et Jonathan,
à cause de Jennifer et Jonathan de la série « Pour l'amour du risque ».
(Rires)
C'est dire s'ils aimaient l'Amérique.
Ils se prenaient pour les Kennedy –
surtout ma mère –
elle nous mettait donc toujours des habits assortis,
nous inscrivait à des cours de bonnes manières, de danse de salon
et elle s'assurait que nous recevions les bons soins dentaires.
(Rires)
C'est une photo de moi, pas un montage.
Dieu merci qu'elle l'ait fait.
J'étais responsable de la caméra à chaque départ en vacances,
j'avais donc toutes ces vidéos, sans savoir quoi en faire.
Mais le Sima Video Ed/it 2,
je les ai convaincus de l'acheter,
et j'ai passé la nuit à me débattre avec les magnétoscopes
de la chambre de mon frère et ma sœur, les fils emmêlés.
J'avais enfin quelque chose à montrer.
Donc un soir, je les ai réunis dans le salon,
on devait être en 1991 environ.
Je les fais s'asseoir dans le salon –
mon cœur palpite, ma respiration s'accélère,
un peu comme maintenant –
j'appuie sur « Lecture »
et quelque chose de merveilleux s'est alors produit.
Ils ont pleuré.
Ils ont beaucoup pleuré.
Non pas car c'était le meilleur montage vidéo au monde –
même si c'était plutôt bon –
(Rires)
mais car ils se sont vus comme une famille normale, qui s'intègre
et a sa place à l'écran, devant eux.
Comme les films qu'ils vénèrent et les séries à l'origine de nos noms.
Étant le benjamin, j'avais le sentiment
d'être entendu pour la première fois.
Il existait un endroit où ces choses dans ma tête
pouvaient prendre vie et s'échapper dans le monde extérieur.
C'est là que j'ai compris
que je voulais faire ça toute ma vie,
que je sois payé ou non pour cela.
J'avais cette passion, j'avais besoin d'outils.
Mon père est allé au travail.
Il s'est vanté de mes compétences en montage vidéo
auprès des clients du Chef Chu's.
Par chance, c'était dans la Silicon Valley,
donc tous travaillaient dans l'informatique, les logiciels –
ce sont tous des ingénieurs.
Ils ont donc proposé de me donner du matériel de montage vidéo numérique.
Nous étions au début des années 1990,
quand ces choses n'existaient pas pour un enfant comme moi.
J'obtenais donc des logiciels et matériels en version bêta venant de HP, de Sun
et de Russell Brown de chez Adobe.
Je n'avais aucun manuel,
alors je les décryptais et je les adorais encore plus.
J'ai commencé les cours à l'école de cinéma de l'USC
et mes parents m'appelaient constamment pour me rappeler
que je devais faire des films sur mon héritage chinois.
La Chine allait devenir un grand marché du cinéma, un jour.
Je leur disais : « Ouais, c'est ça. »
(Rires)
Écoutez toujours vos parents.
Je voulais devenir Zemeckis, Lucas et Spielberg.
La dernière chose dont je voulais parler, c'était mon identité culturelle,
mes origines ethniques.
Honnêtement, je ne parlais à personne –
Je ne pouvais me confier à personne à l'école,
et même si j'avais pu, qu'aurais-je dit ?
Alors j'ai ignoré ça et je suis allé de l'avant.
Quinze ans plus tard,
j'ai percé à Hollywood.
Spielberg me connaît,
j'ai travaillé avec The Rock, Bruce Willis et Justin Bieber.
J'ai même présenté ma troupe de danse, LXD, sur la scène de TED
et c'était super.
Il y a quelques années,
je me suis senti perdu au niveau créatif.
Le moteur ne tournait plus aussi bien
et j'ai reçu un signe...
J'ai entendu des voix venues du ciel,
un peu comme des oiseaux.
Bon OK, c'était Twitter.
Et sur Twitter –
(Rires)
il y avait Constance Wu,
Daniel Dae Kim,
Jenny Yang, qui est ici aujourd'hui,
Alan Yang.
Tous ces gens écrivaient leur frustration
sur la représentativité à Hollywood.
Et ça m'a frappé.
J'avais pensé à ça, mais je ne l'avais jamais noté –
j'étais très concentré –
j'étais chanceux de travailler.
Puis je me suis rendu compte :
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas à Hollywood ?
Pourquoi ne le font-ils pas ?
Je me suis regardé dans le miroir et j'ai vu que Hollywood, c'est moi.
J'ai littéralement –
j'ai relevé mon col avant de venir,
je suis très hollywoodien.
(Rires)
Il est encore relevé ? Parfait.
(Applaudissements)
Toutes ces années, j'ai eu le sentiment d'avoir tant reçu,
sans savoir ce que je rendais à l'industrie du cinéma que j'aime tant.
J'avais la chance d'y être,
mais à ce moment, j'ai compris que ce n'était pas de la chance :
j'avais le droit d'être là.
Non, j'ai gagné le droit d'être là.
Toutes ces nuits blanches, toutes ces soirées manquées le vendredi,
les amis, les petites amies que j'ai perdus à cause des montages –
J'ai gagné le droit d'être là, d'avoir une voix et aussi de dire quelque chose,
de dire des choses importantes
et, enfin, j'avais le pouvoir –
le super-pouvoir de changer les choses si tel était mon désir.
Quand vous essayez de parler de vous
et de ceux qui vous ressemblent ou à votre famille,
cela peut faire peur.
Alors ce sentiment de solitude est revenu.
Mais c'est Internet qui m'a dit –
qui m'a envoyé ce signe, m'a montré mes troupes qui m'attendaient,
me soutenaient et m'aimaient.
J'ai découvert cet incroyable roman de Kevin Kwan : « Crazy Rich Asians »
et on s'est mis au travail.
On a créé ce film tous ensemble.
Un casting 100 % asiatique –
le premier en vingt-cinq ans pour un récit contemporain.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Mais rien n'était joué quand nous avons commencé.
Il n'existait pas de subventions pour ce type de film.
A chaque sondage,
le public ne semblait pas au rendez-vous.
Même lors des projections tests,
quand nous offrons des billets gratuits aux gens pour voir le film,
nous avons eu un ratio de 1 pour 25 :
sur 25 demandes, une seule personne acceptait.
C'est très peu pour ce genre de choses.
Les Asiatiques connaissant le livre se méfiaient de Hollywood,
ceux qui ne le connaissaient pas trouvaient le titre insultant
et toutes les personnes non-asiatiques ne se sentaient pas visées.
On était donc plutôt mal partis.
Heureusement, la Warner ne nous a pas tourné le dos.
Et puis le courant est à nouveau passé,
toute cette armée d'Asio-Américains, d'écrivains, de journalistes et blogueurs,
qui, au fil des ans, avaient gravi les échelons de leurs publications
y ont contribué, à mon insu.
Ils se sont mis à publier des choses.
Des entrepreneurs du numérique ont partagé sur les réseaux sociaux,
ils ont écrit sur nous dans des articles du « Los Angeles Times »,
du « Hollywood Reporter » et de « Entertainment Weekly ».
C'était comme un mouvement spontané qui parlait de nous.
Une chose incroyable à voir.
Et la vague de soutien s'est transformée en conversation en ligne
entre tous ces Asio-Américains.
Nous avons pu débattre et discuter
de ce que nous voulions raconter,
de ce qui devrait l'être ou non,
quel genre de –
pouvons-nous nous moquer de nous-mêmes ?
Et le casting ? Que pouvons-nous faire ?
Nous n'étions pas d'accord – nous ne le sommes toujours pas,
mais ce n'était pas le sujet.
Le fait était que cette discussion avait lieu.
Et ce canal de discussion est devenu permanent.
Il a fallu tous ces groupes différents qui essayaient d'arriver à la même chose
pour nous réunir en ce même tissu conjonctif.
Ce n'était pas parfait,
on a commencé à décider de comment nous représenter sur le grand écran.
Cela s'est matérialisé quand je suis allé au cinéma.
Je n'oublierai jamais la fois où – le premier week-end,
je suis entré et il n'y avait pas que des Asiatiques –
toutes sortes de gens –
j'entre, je m'assieds,
les gens rient, pleurent,
et quand je suis allé dans le hall,
les gens sont restés.
Comme s'ils ne voulaient pas partir.
Ils se sont serrés dans les bras,
tapé dans les mains, se sont pris en selfie,
ils en ont parlé, ils en ont ri.
Tout ça.
J'ai eu une relation si intime avec ce film,
mais je ne comprenais quand nous tournions
ce que nous tournions jusqu'à ce que le film soit produit –
c'était la même chose que ressentaient mes parents en voyant nos vidéos familiales
dans le salon ce jour-là.
Nous voir à l'écran avait le pouvoir de créer ce sentiment
que seul le mot « fierté » peut décrire.
J'ai toujours compris ce mot avec mon cerveau –
j'en avais probablement déjà parlé,
mais de le sentir dans son cœur –
ceux parmi vous qui l'ont sentie le savent –
c'est comme vouloir aimer, toucher tout le monde, attraper et courir partout.
C'est comme un très –
je ne peux pas l'expliquer –
c'est un sentiment très physique,
tout cela grâce à un long écheveau de relations.
Le film est un cadeau qui m'a été offert
et, au fil des ans, j'ai appris beaucoup de choses.
Vous pouvez imaginer, écrire des scripts, réaliser des story-boards,
mais à un certain moment,
votre film vous parlera
et c'est à vous d'écouter.
C'est un organisme vivant et il se présente ainsi,
alors il vaut mieux l'attraper avant qu'il ne glisse de vos mains
et c'est ce qui est passionnant quand on tourne un film.
Quand je regarde la vie, ce n'est pas très différent.
J'ai été guidé par cette sorte de fil d'Ariane de relations
par les gens, par les circonstances,
par la chance.
Cela a changé quand j'ai compris qu'une fois qu'on se met à écouter
les battements silencieux et les bruits confus autour de soi,
on se rend compte qu'une belle symphonie est déjà écrite pour nous.
Tout droit vers notre destin.
Notre super-pouvoir.
Le film est un cadeau qui m'a été offert,
impulsé par mes parents et soutenu par ma communauté.
J'ai réussi à être celui que je voulais quand j'ai eu besoin de l'être.
Ma mère a publié un truc sur Facebook l'autre jour,
c'est souvent une très mauvaise chose à dire tout haut –
flippant, elle ne devrait pas avoir Facebook, mais –
(Rires)
Elle a publié ça, c'est un mème,
un de ces trucs amusants, vous savez,
et il dit : « On ne peut changer quelqu'un qui ne veut pas changer,
mais ne sous-estimez jamais le pouvoir de planter une graine ».
Et alors que je finissais ce discours,
j'ai compris que tous les contacts privilégiés dans ma vie
passaient par la générosité, l'amour, la gentillesse et l'espoir.
Quand je pense à mes films « Crazy Rich Asians », « In the Heights »
sur lequel je travaille aujourd'hui –
(Applaudissements)
Oui, c'est un bon film.
Tout ce que je veux faire, c'est leur montrer la joie et l'espoir,
car je refuse de croire que nos meilleurs jours sont derrière nous,
mais en fait, au coin de la rue.
Car vous voyez l'amour –
l'amour est le super-pouvoir qui m'a été offert.
L'amour est le super-pouvoir qui m'a été transmis.
L'amour est la seule chose qui puisse arrêter une balle
avant même qu'elle ne sorte du barillet.
C'est la seule chose qui peut escalader un bâtiment,
faire regarder un groupe entier vers le ciel,
se donner la main
et avoir le courage d'affronter une chose beaucoup plus grande qu'eux.
J'ai donc un défi pour moi et pour tout le monde ici.
Quand vous travaillez sur vos projets,
sur votre entreprise,
quand vous leur donnez vie et vous rendez possible l'impossible,
n'oublions pas d'être bons les uns envers les autres,
car je crois que c'est la forme de relation la plus puissante
que nous pouvons avoir avec notre planète.
En réalité, notre avenir en dépend.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)